most Americans would not normally trust
the government with helping them you
know like what does the government
actually do to help you and they don't
trust you they help they can help big
corporations industry all the people
that got
you know got those people into Congress
or ultimately to become president those
people all got to get taken care of the
last people I would trust with my health
is Big Pharma and big government because
neither one of those strike me as caring
entities what do people have to see at
this point to realize that the
government does not work for them and
there is one set of political we have
two political main political parties one
set is just about expanding the power of
that thing and one is just this
imperfect usually pretty bad version
that is not really all for that and
sometimes can actually do some really
good stuff like here in Florida that's
kind of where we're at at the moment